assuming you have gone through the
background tutorials of triangles let's
quickly skim through the basics let's
say we have a triangle ABC and just by
looking at you should realize that there
are six things that we are concerned
with three sides and three angles and
based on its sides and angles they are
classified into different types first we
look at classification based on sides if
we have a triangle like this in which
all the sides are equal to each other
then it's called an equilateral triangle
lateral meaning site and equi meaning
equal equal sides
another possibility is when we have a
triangle like this in which just two of
its sides are equal to each other they
are called isosceles triangle and only
one case remains in which no two sides
are equal such triangles are called
scalene triangles
that's how triangles are classified
based on sides what about the
classification based on angles if the
triangle looks like this where all
angles are less than 90 degrees it will
be called an acute triangle remember all
angles less than 90 degrees if one angle
in a triangle is 90 degrees it will be
called a right triangle and if we have a
triangle like this one in which one
angle is greater than 90 degrees then
it's called an obtuse triangle questions
like what if two angles are 90 degrees
or two angles are more than 90 degrees
are not valid those two cases are not
possible as the sum of the angles of a
triangle cannot be more than 180 degrees
but sometimes it gets tricky and we need
to make sure we avoid assumptions we may
be given a triangle like this though it
very much looks like one it may not be a
right triangle or this
triangle which seems to have all its
sides equal to each other may not be
equilateral only if it's explicitly
mentioned like this with a right angle
symbol or with markings which show that
all sides are equal can we know the type
of triangle otherwise make sure you
remember do not assume